GRIFFIN WHO IS TRUMP WHITE
HOUSE COMMUTATIONS DIRECTOR,
AND TOBIN MARCUS, A FORMER
ECONOMIC POLICY ADVISER TO THEN
VICE PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN.
LOOK, THERE IS A LOT THAT
HAPPENED TONIGHT.
WE'VE BEEN WAITING FOR THIS
DEBATE.
IT HAS BEEN WILLING TO BAIT,
WILL THEY NOT DEBATE?
AND NOW IT'S HERE, AND THE
QUESTION IS HOW WOULD THE
PERFORM GIVEN THE STROKE
EXPERIENCE BACK IN MAY.
HE ACTUALLY ADDRESSED IT OFF
THE TOP, IN PART, LET'S PLAY
IT.
>> AND LET'S ALSO TALK ABOUT
THE ELEPHANT IN THE ROOM.
I HAD A STROKE.
HE HAS NEVER LET ME FORGET
THAT.
AND I MIGHT MISS SOME WORDS
DURING THIS DEBATE.
MUSH TWO WORDS TOGETHER.
BUT IF YOU TALK ME NOW, I'M
GOING TO KEEP COMING BACK UP.
AND THIS CAMPAIGN IS ALL ABOUT,
TO ME, FIGHTING FOR EVERYONE IN
PENNSYLVANIA THAT EVER GOT
KNOCKED DOWN.
THAT NEEDS TO GET BACK UP, AND
FIGHTING FOR ALL, ALL
COMMUNITIES ACROSS PENNSYLVANIA
THAT ALSO GOT KNOCKED DOWN THAT
NEEDS TO KEEP GETTING BACK UP.
>> WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT THAT,
THE IDEA OF HOW HE TURNED IT
INTO A DISCUSSION, REALLY ABOUT,
LOOK, I AM THE EVERY PERSON.
ONE, WAS THAT AFFECTIVE TO YOU?
THAT WASN'T THE MOMENT PEOPLE
WERE TALKING ABOUT AND
STRUGGLING, FRANKLY.
BUT THE IDEA OF TALKING ABOUT
IT IN THAT CONTEXT, YOU ARE
WAITING FOR THIS DEBATE, WAS
THAT PERSUASIVE TO YOU AS A WAY
TO SET THE STAGE?
>> NO, IT REALLY WAS NOT.
I THOUGHT SOMEBODY SHOULD VOTE
THE MERCY RULE 20 MINUTES INTO
THE DEBATE.
FETTERMAN, IN MY VIEW, I DON'T
KNOW IF IT WAS THE STROKE OR
HE'S JUST A LOUSY DEBATER OR IF
HE DOESN'T UNDERSTAND THE
ISSUES.
HE WAS FLUSTERED HE, WAS
CONFUSED.
HE SHOULD HAVE NOT BEEN OUT
THERE.
AND I'VE HAD A NUMBER OF PEOPLE
SAY WHY WAS THIS GUY IN ON THE
BALLOT AFTER THAT?
I DON'T KNOW IF THE DEBATES
MATTER THAT MUCH.
BUT PEOPLE WATCH THAT, THEY ARE
GOING TO QUESTION HIS CAPACITY
TO SERVE.
THE BAR WAS SET VERY LOW.
IT SHOULD'VE BEEN SET LOWER.
>> ON THAT POINT, YOU'VE TALKED
ABOUT THAT TOO, ALISYN, THE BAR
WAS SET SO LOW IN THE SENSE OF
DOCTOR OZ YOU KNOW HIM BECAUSE
HE'S THE TELEVISION
PERSONALITY.
>> HE'S ON TV, HE'S BEEN DOING
IT FOR TWO DECADES.
THAT'S WHAT JOHN FETTERMAN WAS
SAYING.
BUT THIS WAS IN A DIFFERENT
CATEGORY, IT SOUNDS LIKE.
SO, LET'S LISTEN TO A MOMENT
WHERE JOHN FETTERMAN STRUGGLES,
SEEMED TO STRUGGLE.
>> I'M ALSO HAVING --
TALK ABOUT SOMETHING CALLED THE
OZ RULE.
THAT IF HE'S ON TV, HE'S LYING.
HE DID THAT DURING HIS CAREER
ON HIS TV SHOW.
HE'S DONE THAT DURING HIS
CAMPAIGN ABOUT LYING, ABOUT OUR
RECORD HERE.
AND HE'S ALSO LYING, PROBABLY,
DURING THIS DEBATE.
>> I WANT TO BRING CIVILITY,
BALANCE, ALL OF THE THINGS YOU
WANT TO --
BECAUSE EVEN TELLING THEM TO ME
ON THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL.
AND BY DOING THAT, WE CAN BRING
US TOGETHER IN A WAY THAT HAS
NOT BEEN DONE OF LATE.
DEMOCRATS, REPUBLICANS, TALKING
TO EACH OTHER.
JOHN FETTERMAN TAKES EVERYTHING
TO AN EXTREME.
AND THOSE EXTREME POSITIONS
HURT US ALL.
>> ALYSSA, YOUR THOUGHTS AS HE
WATCHED?
THAT >> DOCTOR OZ HAS THE
ADVANTAGE OF A CAREER ON TV.
HE'S AN EXCELLENT COMMUNICATOR
BUT.
THAT IS NOT WHY HE WON
TONIGHT'S DEBATE.
HE HIT ON EVERY MAJOR ISSUE
THAT VOTERS ARE FOCUSED.
ON THE ECONOMY, CRIME IN
PENNSYLVANIA A HUGE ISSUE,
ENERGY, HE HAD SUBSTANCE BEHIND
HIM.
AND THERE'S THIS UNIFYING
GENERAL ELECTION MESSAGE.
I WANT TO BE CAREFUL BECAUSE I
THINK SOME OF THE MOST
CONSEQUENTIAL LEADERS IN
HISTORY HAVE HAD DIFFERENT
KINDS OF DISABILITIES.
I DON'T THINK IT SHOULD
PRECLUDE SOMEONE FROM SERVING.
BUT WHAT WE SAW TODAY WAS
SOMEONE WHO WAS NOT READY TO BE
IN OFFICE.
AND THE LACK OF TRANSPARENCY
LEADING UP TO THIS ACTUALLY
SHOCKED PEOPLE WATCHING.
IT I FOUND IT EXTREMELY HARD TO
WATCH.
AND THE QUESTION I FOUND MYSELF
ASKING IS THE WAY THAT HE'S
STRUGGLING A RESULT OF HIS
STROKE?
OR IS IT BECAUSE HE DOES NOT
HAVE A GRASP ON THE ISSUES?
HE WAS ASKED A VERY DIRECT
QUESTION WHAT HIS POSITION ON
FRACKING.
HE COULD NOT EXPLAIN WHY HE
FUNDAMENTALLY CHANGE HIS
POSITION ON.
IT AND THE VOTERS DESERVE TO
KNOW THAT.
>> I WANT TO PLAY THAT.
BECAUSE HONESTLY, AND TOBIN I
WANT TO HEAR YOUR TAKE ON THIS
AS WELL, BECAUSE WHAT WE PLAYED
SO FAR, FRANKLY, FOR THE
AUDIENCE WHO MAY HAVE NOT SEEN
THESE DEBATE, I DON'T KNOW IT'S
CONVEYING THAT LEVEL OF
DIFFICULTY ANSWERING THE
QUESTIONS AS MUCH AS WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT IT RIGHT NOW.
I WANT YOU TO RESPOND, TOBIN.
BUT LET'S PLAY THE MOMENT
YOU'RE SAYING, ALYSSA, THAT IS
REALLY SUGGESTIVE AND
ILLUSTRATIVE OF THE POINT THAT
YOU ARE MAKING.
>> I ALWAYS BELIEVE THAT
INDEPENDENTS WITH OUR ENERGY IS
CRITICAL.
WE CAN'T BE HELD, YOU KNOW,
RANSOM TO SOMEBODY LIKE RUSSIA.
YOU KNOW, I'VE ALWAYS BELIEVED
THAT ENERGY INDEPENDENCE IS
CRITICAL.
AND I'VE ALWAYS BELIEVED THAT.
AND I DO SUPPORT FRACKING.
>> I DO WANT TO CLARIFY
SOMETHING.
YOU'RE SAYING TONIGHT THAT YOU
SUPPORT FRACKING, THAT YOU'VE
ALWAYS SUPPORTED FRACKING?
BUT THERE IS THAT 2018
INTERVIEW WHERE YOU SAID, QUOTE,
I DO NOT SUPPORT FRACKING AT
ALL.
SO HOW DO YOU SQUARE THE TWO?
>> OH, I DO SUPPORT FRACKING.
AND I DON'T, I DON'T --
I SUPPORT FRACKING.
AND I STAND, AND I DO SUPPORT
FRACKING.
>> TOBIN?
>> YEAH, THE FRACKING ANSWER
THAT HE GAVE WAS ONE OF THE
LOWER MOMENTS IN A GENERALLY
TOUGH PERFORMANCE.
I THINK THE CLIP THAT YOU
PLAYED IMMEDIATELY BEFORE THAT,
HIM SORT OF TRYING TO LAY OUT
THE BOSS RULE, WAS AN ATTEMPT
TO GUARD AGAINST WHAT HE KNEW
WAS GOING TO BE A LOT OF
INCOMING FIRE HE WAS GOING TO
TAKE.
OZ CAME IN ATTEMPTING TO
PORTRAY HIM AS RADICAL, THAT'S
CLOONEY THE STRATEGY.
I THINK HE KNEW HE WAS NOT
GOING TO HAVE THE NIMBLENESS TO
RESPOND TO THOSE IN REALTIME.
SO, HE WAS TRYING TO MAKE A
CERTAIN BLANKET EFFORT TO, YOU
KNOW, CREATE AN ISSUE AROUND
HONESTY AND SORT OF VALIDITY OF
ALL HIS ATTACKS.
BUT FOR ANYONE WHO'S COMING
INTO THIS TOTALLY UNDECIDED, IF
YOU DROP VOTER INTO HARRISBURG
WITH NO ENGAGEMENT ON THIS
BEFOREHAND, IT'S HARD TO SEE
THEM COMING AWAY TERRIBLY,
TERRIBLY CONVINCED BY FETTERMAN
THEY'RE.
>> WE SHOULD MENTION THAT HE
WAS USING CLOSE CAPTIONING.
SO, HE WAS USING --
HE WAS ABLE TO READ THE
QUESTIONS AND THE WORDS RATHER
THAN JUST HEARING THEM.
BECAUSE HE'S ADMITTED HE HAS
AUDITORY PROCESSING ISSUES NOW
BECAUSE OF THE STROKE.
AND YOU KNOW, CHARLIE, I'VE
INTERVIEWED HIM MANY TIMES AS
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR.
AND HE SOUNDS --
HE'S OUT A DIFFERENT BEFORE THE
STROKE.
IN THE INTERVIEWS, HE WAS MUCH
MORE SORT OF CLEAR SPOKEN AND
WHAT I'M HEARING.
NOW HERE'S A MOMENT WHERE THEIR
TALK ABOUT THEIR DIFFERENCES ON
THE ECONOMY.
SO, LET'S PLAY THAT.
>> I CAN MAKE THE DIFFICULT
DECISIONS, AS YOU DO IN THE
OPERATING ROOM AS A SURGEON.
I WILL MAKE THEM CUTTING OUR
BUDGET AS WELL, TO MAKE SURE WE
DON'T HAVE TO RAISE TAXES ON A
POPULATION ALREADY DESPERATELY
IN PAIN FROM THE HIGH INFLATION
RATE.
>> HE HAS NEVER MET ON AN OIL
COMPANY THAT HE DOES NOT SWIPE
RIGHT ABOUT.
HE HAS NEVER BEEN ABLE TO STAND
UP FOR WORKING FAMILIES ALL
ACROSS PENNSYLVANIA.
WE MUST PUSH BACK.
INFLATION HAS HURT AMERICA AND
PENNSYLVANIA'S FAMILIES.
IT HAS GIVEN THE OIL COMPANIES
RECORD PROFITS.
>> I'M GLAD YOU PLAY, THAT
ALISYN.
BECAUSE I FEEL LIKE WE'VE BEEN
HEARING A LOT ABOUT ALL THE
THINGS HE DID WRONG.
AND I HAVE, YOU KNOW, NO SKIN
IN THE GAME IN THIS PARTICULAR
RACE.
BUT WHY WE DID PLAY SOMETHING
THAT TO DEMONSTRATE, I DID NOT
THINK IT WAS SOMETHING THAT WAS
SO PROBLEMATIC COMPARED TO THE
JUXTAPOSITION THAT WE SAW
EARLIER.
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, I JUST SEEMS
LIKE THESE ANSWERS WERE NOT
PARTICULARLY COHERENT.
AND I'M BEING KIND WHEN I SAY
THAT.
ON ENERGY, PENNSYLVANIA IS THE
SECOND LARGEST GAS PRODUCING
STATE IN THE NATION.
I WANT TO HEAR HIM EXPLAIN HIS
EVOLUTION.
HE COULD NOT DO IT.
I SUPPORT FRACKING, I SUPPORT
--
>> WHILE, HE DIDN'T, BUT HE
COULD NOT EXPLAIN.
IT WE WANT TO HEAR HIM TALK
ABOUT CRIME AND HIS ROLE ON THE
BOARD OF PARTY.
AND I DIDN'T HEAR ANYTHING THAT
EXPLAIN HIS RATIONALE FOR SOME
OF THE DECISIONS, HIGHLY
QUESTIONABLE STATIONS, HE MADE
THERE.
HE WAS NOT ABLE TO ARTICULATE
WHAT IT WAS THAT HE STOOD FOR.
AND THAT WAS WHAT WAS REALLY
TROUBLING TO ME.
AGAIN, I ALMOST FEEL VERY
SORELY FOR HIM.
THAT HE'S IN A BAD WAY.
BUT AS A VOTER, I'M SAYING, HOW
CAN I VOTE FROM SOMEBODY WHO I
DO NOT THINK IS READY TO DO THE
JOB.
>> WHAT DO YOU THINK, TOBIN?
BECAUSE YOU WORKED FOR THE VICE
PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN AT THE
TIME.
AND TRUTH BE TOLD, HE WAS
CRITICIZED, AT TIMES, FOR NOT
BEING AS NIMBLE AS HE ONCE WAS.
OBVIOUSLY, DIFFERENT REASONS.
HE WAS CRITICIZED FOR THE WAY
IN WHICH HE WOULD ARTICULATE
CERTAIN POINTS.
AND THERE IS ALWAYS A BIT OF
WIND IN THE FACE OF THEN
CANDIDATE BIDEN ON THAT VERY
POINT.
WHEN YOU'RE LOOKING AT IT FROM
THAT PERSPECTIVE, DO YOU SEE
THESE SAME CONCERNS THAT THEY
ARE TALKING ABOUT?
>> I THINK THE STRAINS OF
PRESIDENT BIDEN AS A CAMPAIGNER
LINES UP WITH FETTERMAN,
DESPITE HIS IMPAIRMENTS, I
THINK HE CAN EXIT THE LEVEL
VALUES WITH VOTERS AND.
HIS CAMPAIGN IS MADE THAT A
VERY INTENTIONAL FOCUS.
HIS BLUE-COLLAR LANDING MAKES
THE LACK OF POLISH FORGIVABLE
TO VOTERS WHO ARE INCLINED TO
SUPPORT.
HIM AND I THINK FRANKLY IN THIS
DEBATE, DESPITE WHAT WAS, YOU
KNOW OBJECTIVELY A ROUGH
PERFORMANCE BY FETTERMAN.
PEOPLE WHO ARE INCLINED TO BE
SYMPATHETIC TO ONE CANDIDATE OR
THE OTHER PROBABLY CAME AWAY
WITH ENOUGH TO SORT OF
REINFORCE WHERE THEY WERE.
>> YOU DON'T THINK IT'S CHANGED
THE MOMENTUM?
>> GIVEN HOW PEOPLE GENERALLY
WATCH THESE THINGS, IT'S HARD
FOR ME TO SEE THIS BEING A BIG
INFLECTION POINT IN THE POLLING,
GIVEN HOW TIGHT THINGS ARE.
NEGATIVE PARTNERSHIP IS
POWERFUL, PEOPLE HAVE A LOT OF
REASONS TO BE WHERE THEY ARE.
THIS IS THE BATTLE FOR THE
CONTROL OF THE SENATE, MORE SO
THAN THE CONTENTS OR THE
CANDIDATE.
>> TO PUT A BOW ON THIS, JOE
BIDEN IS --
CRITICAL OF GAS AND STATEMENTS,
STRUGGLING TO GET DIFFERENT
SENTENCES OUT.
BUT I'VE NEVER BEEN CONCERNED
THAT HE HAS A GRASP ON THE
POLICY ISSUES, EVEN IF I
DISAGREE WITH HIS POLICIES.
THIS WAS A CANDIDATE WHERE I
WAS GENTLE WHEN UNCLEAR IF HE
UNDERSTOOD HOW TO ADDRESS CRIME,
HOW TO JUST ECONOMY AND
INFLATION.
AND THEN HE DID TRY TO LOG
ATTACKS ON OZ, THEY DID NOT
LAND.
IT DID NOT SEEM HE HAD A FULL
GRASP.
HE WENT AFTER HIM ON WANTING TO
CUT MEDICARE AND SOCIAL
SECURITY.
OZ WAS READY FOR IT, AND HE WAS
NOT ABLE TO ARTICULATE.
SO I'M NOT A PENNSYLVANIA VOTER,
BUT THE MODEM --
MOMENTUM WAS ON OZ'S SIDE.
>> WE KNOW THERE'S ALREADY BEEN
640 PRE ELECTION VOTES AREN'T
CAST.
>> I'M ONE OF THEM.
>> AND --
I'VE GONE TO DEMOCRATS, VERSUS
19% TO REPUBLICANS.
AND THE IDEA IS IF THE DEBATES
DON'T MATTER, I WONDER TO WHAT
EXTENT THIS DOES NOT WORK.
BUT THERE'S REALLY A BIG ISSUE.
ON THE ISSUE OF IMMIGRATION,
FOR THOSE ISSUES THAT HAVE NOT
USUALLY BEEN A TALKING POINT IN
THE STATE OF PENNSYLVANIA
COMPARED TO OTHER PLACES, THEY
ADDRESS THAT POINT TONIGHT.
LISTEN TO THIS.
>> I UNDERSTAND WHAT ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION OFFERS US.
BUT THE COMPLETELY POROUS, OPEN
NATURE OF OUR BORDER, WHICH
JOHN FETTERMAN SUPPORTS, HAS
CREATED A HUMANITARIAN CRISIS.
WITH CARTELS PROFITING, WITH
HUMAN TRAFFICKING OPERATIONS,
THEY TAKE THE MONEY, THEY BUY
NARCOTICS FROM CHINA AND BRING
THAT INTO OUR COUNTRY.
IT'S MAKING EVERY STATE A
BORDER STATE.
PENNSYLVANIA IS ALREADY A
BORDERS STAY BECAUSE WE'RE TOP
THREE IN THE COUNTRY AND
FENTANYL OVERDOSES.
>> I BELIEVE A SECURE BORDER
CAN BE COMPATIBLE WITH
COMPASSION.
I BELIEVE WE NEED A
COMPREHENSIVE AND BIPARTISAN
SOLUTION FOR IMMIGRATION.
THAT'S WHAT I BELIEVE.
I DON'T EVER RECALL IN THE
STATUE OF LIBERTY THAT THEY SAY,
YOU KNOW, TAKE ARE TIRED,
HUDDLED MASSES AND PUT THEM ON
A BUS.
AND USE CHEAP POLITICAL STUNTS
ABOUT THEM.
>> WHAT DID YOU THINK, CHARLIE?
THAT WAS A GOOD --
>> THAT WAS ONE OF HIS BETTER
ANSWERS OF THE NIGHT.
AGAIN, I JUST AM STILL
ASTOUNDED, I'M STILL STUNNED BY
WHAT I WITNESSED TONIGHT.
AND THIS IS --
THEY SHOULD'VE HAD MORE DEBATES,
BY THE WAY.
AND THIS IS A BIG STATE.
THERE SHOULD BE AT LEAST TWO
DEBATES, PROBABLY THREE.